en moselle les gendarmes ont entendu
tout au long de cette journée
francis heaulme déjà plusieurs fois
condamné pour des crimes ces gendarmes
sont chargés d'une enquête en révision
du procès de patrick dils qui fut accusé
en 1986 du meurtre de deux enfants
s'était à montigny-lès-metz patrick dils
clame son innocence en prison et
l'hypothèse d'une culpabilité de francis
heaulme dans ces crimes est de plus en
plus évoqué les gendarmes aurait la
preuve de ses mensonges
l'explication valérie remis christian
hutin une garde à vue que les gendarmes
de metz attendait depuis longtemps
depuis qu'ils ont réussi à prouver que
francis heaulme a menti sur son emploi
du temps du 28 septembre 86 ce jour là
où il me dit avoir croisé alexandre et
cyril retrouvés assassinés à
montigny-lès-metz mais ni les avoir tués
pour preuve un ami à lui pascal dollé
avec eole me dit avoir passé
l'après-midi
mais devant les enquêteurs pascal de les
déments francis heaulme en dit aussi
être rentrée chez sa grand-mère en
moselle
ce serait encore un mensonge il n'y
vivaient plus depuis 10 mois
enfin au le me parle de bière achetée
dans une épicerie le jour des meurtres
impossible l'épicerie était fermé depuis
plusieurs mois cette accumulation de
mensonges désormais prouver et pour
l'avocat de patrick dils une avancée
décisive dans le dossier je crois que
c'est un grand pas qui devrait déboucher
très rapidement sur sa mise en examen et
sur la libération de patrick 10 et sur
enfin la reconnaissance de son innocence
devant les enquêteurs
en six ans le mât dû s'expliquer sur
toutes les contradictions
ce sera à la cour de révision qui a
ordonné cette audition d'en tirer les
conséquences
elle seule peut décider d'annuler ou non
la condamnation de patrick dils